on everybody we accept in the morning to
listen about fonts so when one person is
really interested in phones today so the
first question is not a philosophical
question okay so I it would be even
worse to talk about philosophy in 10 in
the morning I just want to say a little
bit about myself
so you know who I am in and you know who
is talking about this stuff so I've
studied in college the rainiest city 90
kilometers from here I studied graphic
design like 10 years ago
and then at at a moment I decided that I
wanted to design fonts I was I was a bit
concerned that everything that I did in
the graphic design world was a bit
disposable like I designed the poster
and the next day after the date of the
venue the poster would go to trash and I
I was thinking what can I do graphic
design why's that that will last and and
typography I found that it's something
that lasts we use nowadays phones with
like 500 years old
so I started freelancing and started
designing my my own font my my first
font was called or is called eggs oh
this is a free font is it's available on
google fonts it started as a Kickstarter
project and then it evolved Google
Commission like a few more scripts so
now it is like extended Cyrillic support
and so on it's it's one of the most used
fonts on the web it's in the top 100
feel free to use it it's it's free it's
open source and it has it like millions
of downloads I cannot even like count I
was I was walking
around then I saw like a pop-up thing
that was using eggs oh one of my phones
so it's it's basically everywhere which
makes me pretty happy then after that I
designed this font also commissioned by
Google it's it's it's called Caesar
maybe some of you know it's also pretty
popular it's a design inspired in first
century Roman inscriptions so it was
really fun to do and then I started
doing like some more commercial things
because Google didn't invest more money
in fonts so I had to start selling my my
designs so I did this one first called
Monica and then something more script
more playful more fun I always try to
have fun while I'm working on these
things no need to get too much boredom
out of your work and then this is a new
version of exa with like rounded corners
it's softer and then these called Nazeri
it's inspired in a small fishing village
known for its big waves in the west
coast and then I did this one it is like
really intense kind of work it has 64
styles a lot in Greek Cyrillic and
emojis so it's like more than a thousand
glyphs font and then this geometric
design called point another script and
something more industrial it was my
latest release ok but I was just an
introduction about myself one question
that I get asked a lot is do we need new
fonts so people normally ask ask this
one and I think that's that's a good
question like most people might not see
the need for a new font but usually I
like to counter it with with another
question like do we need new chairs we
need
time to design a new chair or or do we
need new music so there's there's a part
in typography there's a that is a
creative expression that we cannot get
rid of but even if we get if we put that
aside I want to show you today that that
there are still things that need to be
done in the world of fonts even even if
you look at it in the most pragmatical
technical way and I want to prove you
that there's still a lot of thing to be
done on that regard a better question is
do we need good fonts like I know that
we have thousands of fonts but are they
good do they serve the purpose well can
we trust those fonts like I know that
you can go to the font calm and there's
like millions or thousands of fonts
available but but are they good will
they honor the project that you're
working with so and we must talk about a
few things like legibility read ability
and do the font convey the right feeling
does it have enough language support so
legibility is the ability to distinguish
one shape from another so one common
example is like using my pointer if you
if you look at this o NDC there are
about lowercase if you're reading this
shape like at six pixel or eight pixel
size there might be a chance that the C
would look like an O because this is a
very tight space so when we talk about
legibility you would use like a font
that has open counters another example
is like this is a one this is a
uppercase I and this is a lowercase L
but like in this font all these shapes
look the same so this is a good test
that you can do to see if the the font
is a good legibility of course if you're
using it for like display purposes
I mean that's okay but then when you're
talking about chunks of text like if
you're if you if you're working like you
know a newspaper website you need to
really to focus on those things
so and most phones don't don't pay much
attention about these these sort of
details
another thing is readability readability
is different from legibility why is that
readability has to do with the ability
to read for a long period of time
without fatigue so most of you probably
have found like a website there's like a
dark background and white collar or
bright color font see you cannot read it
for too long it gets you get a lot of
fatigue so and there are things that you
can do to to avoid the fatigue one thing
is to have like more serif light phones
that they have more contrast contrast is
the relationship between thick strokes
and thinner strokes so try to have like
more distinction between the shapes the
brain process it faster when the shapes
are not just like symmetry and rotation
so when the shapes have like these
little differences the brain processes
it faster and it doesn't have to like do
that much effort so you can read for
longer periods of time so other thing is
language coverage so I don't know if you
have that experience when you like paste
a text that you copied from somewhere
and there's like some some words that
there are from another language and then
these little sign that we used to call
tofu appears and speaking about I don't
know if you have heard about a Google
font called Noto it stands for no tofu
so it's the first font that supports
every single language in the world so
and most of the fonts only have Lawton
support and a very small lot in super
support only for like some European
languages
and when we're talking about do we need
good fonts we need to think about Indic
scripts Chinese scripts Korean so and
not only like Latin scripts so there's
still a lot to be done
I myself have worked in Indic scripts I
have worked in a font that is gone
Google Fonts called ARIMA it has like
Tamil and Malayalam support which are a
language from the south of India and and
it amazed me that like the people in the
designers there I'd like only like 5
fonts to work with so when you when
you're when you're thinking about we
need new fonts you should think do do we
but do other people that have other
scripts need new fonts need creativity
to express themselves so yes do we need
new fonts on that regard so this is this
is also a little play that I like to do
it's that fonts convey a meaning other
than the content okay so here is Comic
Sans the beloved font and you you see
that I have exactly the same content on
the top and on the bottom but like the
messages is totally different
so you need to be careful because the
font that you're using to type things
might be saying a different thing than
the content that you're typing so that's
that's something that you that we should
be careful and we should be aware of
that even if we decide that we want like
a really neutral font that doesn't
convey any meaning like something like
Helvetica which people used to say that
is neutral I don't believe that but
people say that and another another
thing that we must consider is like do
we have sufficient style versatility
like if the phone that you use only have
the regular style like you're very
limited especially when you want to have
some year key of information and when
you can have like black bold italic
you can have all these sorts of
variations that make the the traveling
through the the information much much
easier so this is the reason why we need
better font we need phones with more
styles so so designers can can
communicate better and lastly we need
phones that have a good print and screen
optimization I know that we all live in
the age of Retina displays but not
everybody uses retina displays you know
the kid in in like subsidy in Africa is
going to a library that has a very low
resolution display and we still need to
account for that until everybody has
retina displays and for that we need a
thing called anything so hinting you see
it like this is giorgia
it's the Matthew Carter designed for
Microsoft so what you see is like there
are custom adjustments in the design
according to each size so this is 9 10
11 and 12 pixels and when you change the
design you adjust the pixel grid so it
reads better so ear on the on the right
you have an hinted lowercase G and you
have a hinted lowercase G so this is
just the difference of a pixel but like
this will look a mess when you're
reading like a 12 pixels and this will
look really good and these things are
really important and designers take care
of that nowadays thank God like 99% of
the job is done by an algorithm but the
designers still need to check
everything's ok so you need to search
for fonts that they have good
optimization so I want to go to the
future of fonts I'm pretty much talking
about the present of fonts but before I
go to the future we need to go to the
past well why do I think I need to go to
the best because we need to see the
trajectory of the evolution of
typography what is happening what is the
trajectory and you can only see the
trajectory when we have two points and
one point is the present and the other
point will be the past
you cross a line and hopefully we
extrapolate but we try to understand
where things might go this is like
fortune-telling but we need to do our
best and so just just to clarify a thing
for the for easiness of comprehension
I'm always using the the therm font
even though font relates to the file
itself you know and not to the design so
type designers like me like to talk
about type and typography but for for
communication sake I will refer to font
just destroy it we have an idea like a
font is to an mp3 like type is to music
okay the font is the file the the the
thing that that contains the design when
the type is the design itself so really
really fast traveling around like five
thousand years so humans decided to draw
some things that represent some things
so it's called pictograms and then
humans said oh but we can also represent
sounds and not just things and then
phonogram starts though so a is the
phonogram it has a sound ah and we
design it like this and then the Romans
developed the capital e SH monumentally
so the the words that they chiseled on
the big buildings and he might come as a
surprise but up until this point there
were no lowercase fonts so only a per
case and then new tools of writing
emerged like brushes and sort of pencils
and when these these things started to
happen so it's a technology evolution
people started abandoning this this form
of writing because it took too much time
and and started writing in different
ways so this is where the lowercase
which is you can connect the syllables
with one another started to to appearing
and then you have gotten birth like
invented the printed press
like not so but more or less invented
the printed press and like a revolution
began so now we have people casting
metal type and we have these little
things made of lead that we can like
print 200 books like in a month so which
was a great evolution looking back to
the coppiced monks that took years and
then with the Industrial Revolution
there was like an explosion of
possibilities a lot of designers started
expressing themselves through typography
is was no longer something only used to
convey text meaning but like to express
something artistically and then people
started a digitalization of typography
which is what we have now so we can have
like on screens fonts so this this
happens through a long period of time
but what can we learn from here is that
technology technology drives fonts ok so
when new technology happens new design
opportunities happen and this is what we
are seeing now at the moment that we are
reaching what I call the future of fonts
so but even talking a little bit about
the present of phones because most
people might not know what the state of
things are at the moment so before
OpenType we add like TrueType you are
familiar with these concepts so what
open typed was was like a lying design
with code so and once again it was
technology that drive new advancements
in design so what UK what you can do
with open type so this is fun this is
one that I made and basically what I say
is this if there's character that is an
no descender on the left and no
descender on the right
you can change this shape for this shape
so it's a very simple code so
but we're starting a line code we design
and we can say that when an F and I are
very close together we can change that
with this shape it reads better like
it's strange on this size but when you
read ik it on like 12 pixel size it
works really well or when you write like
a 1/4 it converts automatically to a
fraction number or you can have like
alternate designs on the beginning of of
words so this is just example there are
plenty of open type features so this is
where we are at the moment we are
aligned code with design so so we have
like more opportunities of design and
now we are obviously design designing in
native digital support so I designed
mostly on the computer I just make some
rough sketches on paper and then I go
directly to the computer and then I
don't know maybe 10 years ago we had the
web font boom I know how many web
designers are here so I can know okay so
the word designs that are here remember
when you had to use you had to rely on
system fonts you remember that like
there there weren't that many web fonts
available so web fonts was really like a
boom and it was so important because
when people wanted to use different
fonts that were not like system fonts
they relied on image or complex scripts
and that made a really big problem
it made the web less searchable so
Google invested like some millions of
dollars to making the web more
searchable and created like google fonts
you know it says like almost a thousand
fonts and the goal behind all that like
if you question why would Google
investing fonts it's basically that make
the web more searchable get rid of those
complex creeps get rid of images and
let's save web fonts so web fonts was
really like a huge step forward because
most designers would like to express
themselves in print backgrounds
because they have more possibilities and
now they can express themselves totally
on web the web design so that's that's
awesome
now the future of fonts the future of
fonts is called variable fonts like it's
a very new technology that is happening
and what I'm showing here is like the
old way or the present way of doing
stuff like the designer designed like
the regular style and the bold and then
this display regular display bold so
this is are normally things would have
happen but now we with variables let me
see if the the video is working
oops it should be not a place sorry so I
guess I will have to explain what
happens such a shame so I oh it's it's
playing now so this this is just me
playing around in Illustrator and now
illustrator as a variable font support
so there's this little icon like on the
top that I'm gonna press and that opens
a slider and now you don't have like
specific weights you have like a slider
and you can control the font and this is
not just a gimmick it like it it is
really really important and I will
explain in a minute so in in type design
we add interpolation which is basically
what is happening so I I design lets me
go back I design this one and I designed
this one and then I can interpolate in
between these two weights but now what
happened now we have a support it's
called variable fonts and now I don't
have to store like in my server all the
different styles that I need I can
like the one single file the variable
font filed what what do these do like I
have a significantly reduced file size
so especially when you have like a lot
of scripts fonts get heavy as always
saying like Google no 2 as like 1
gigabyte so it's really a lot so in many
we have like variable fonts you
significally significantly can reduce
the file size you can also have like
fine-tuned adjustment you know you're
not sorry satisfied with the bold weight
that you have and then with code you
just give it a little bit more or you
can control like when when the site
migrates from a desktop to a responsive
stance you can adjust make minimal
adjustments so you have better
readability
so everybody is investing on these
things Heppell Microsoft Google Addo
monotype and most browsers nowadays have
support for these sort of fonts even
though they are not available you cannot
buy them I don't know where you can buy
them but some people are making
experience experiments and making them
available so this is probably the the
future of fonts where like if you're
standing at the distance it changes a
little bit the shape of the font or if
if you and if you so you can read the
best so what will happen is like there's
more power to the user and a lot of
possibilities and as it said with great
power comes great responsibility what
will happen is like with the verge of
variable fonts the users will need to
know more about typography because the
apex of variables would be like every
single possible font will be in one
single file can you imagine having only
one file in your computer you can have
like an axis that you control the
seraphs of the phone
in another the height of the Sanders and
the dissenters so the possibilities will
increase for the common user so and this
is especially important for me that I'm
a typography teacher I need to teach
better my students to use typography
well because things will not be that
easy if you if we get to the point of
having like these variable fonts with
like thousands of possibilities you
really need to know what you're doing
another feature of fonts maybe is a
module why am I saying that because it's
it's not really like an illustration
because if you use like iOS or if you go
to Android each one has a different set
of emojis so these little things are
being understood now as characters you
know and each one each brand is
designing them in a way and are trying
to make them the most readable as
possible you know so it's it's it feels
like going back you know to pictograms
but it's going forward because these
things communicate a lot in a very short
amount of time you know just press a
single thing so it will this be also the
future of font design will we have to
include the emojis in our font maybe I
don't know also like as things evolve
new characters need to be designed so
there's once a time that this character
didn't exist and there's once the time
that this character didn't exist and I
just did this really roughly maybe this
is Bitcoin I don't know will will the
phones need to support all these new
characters there that it there are
flourishing and like we have I don't
know how many cryptocurrencies do we
have do we need to include that in our
phones now that we are designing so this
is a question for for the designers may
be the future of fonts is also including
all the new characters and all the new
forms of expression that are available
on a more branding side like the few
fons is also customized so every brand
is now looking for custom forms this is
just an example of IBM that recently
changed the font that they use so for
you to have an idea IBM paid in
royalties a million dollars a year in
royalties twelve Etica for a vertical so
and it's it's a very small investment
comparing to what they are saving now
and a lot of brands are doing that
because non totally they save money but
they have like an additional branding
asset so especially like IBM which
release this open-source now people have
this font on their computer and are
searching for font IBM IBM it's like
unconscious voice IBM IBM IBM so this is
what happened and a lot of brands are
customizing like Apple all the Google
Netflix all major brands and evils even
some medium and small brands are
investment creating their own type
because people realize that why am i
using Arial or L vatika or Verdana when
I can have my own font when I can
communicate in a very single and unique
way so this is also one thing that is
happening in and also something that is
happening is new economic models so
people are maybe it's it's too early to
say but people are no longer buying that
much fonts and now they are resorting to
these sort of services and these
services are like the Spotify of fonts
you know in adult fonts you subscribe to
their Creative Cloud and you have access
to the Alphonse Alfonso of the dog and
phone town works really like Spotify you
pay a subscription and you can have the
the fonts like you don't really have
access to the font but you but you can
use them in illustrator or word can use
it in your software and you have like
fonts 10 which rents fonts because most
designers only use the font for one
month or something and then don't use it
so they have the model of renting fonts
so this is also the future the future of
fonts new new economic model
that are popping out so but what what
could be beyond the future of phones
because we are on the verge of the
future but can we extrapolate and try to
think what what could happen in the
future
so and maybe we'll say I designed the
phones for ourselves I don't know but I
think we I said that we wouldn't be
philosophical but maybe this is a very
important question is why do we design
it's it's maybe not only to have a very
good product but because it's an
expression of ourselves you know and
that's why I believe that craft will
always happen if even if it's not the
best way now if you do your own share
you will love it in a way that you won't
love a chair that you buy on IKEA so and
this is like a part of creativity
process maybe we won't let a I design
fonts for us because we want to do it
ourselves
so thank you thank you so very much this
is my website you can go there and
download there my free fonts my paid
phones are on my phones and if you use
these code you can have like a discount
I'm opening up now for questions if
someone has any question are there any
mics there okay
I thank you for a presentation really
interesting insightful lots of new stuff
like about the purpose of Google Fonts
it's so obvious but I never leave that
about I have one question but more about
your craft okay and regarding the like
the support for international languages
how do you ensure that you're getting it
right in in languages as well I assume
you're not fluent in Tamil and Russian
and mullerian so how do you ensure that
when you're giving identity to a
typeface you're not getting it wrong for
let's say imagine you have a character
in a certain script that looks like like
an F yeah in fact it's not an F and you
start giving it identity with the F
mindset and you get something that is
actually wrong for what the origin of
that character is yeah that's how do you
ensure that in terms of either your
knowledge or partnering with right that
is a very good question and what I do
and like most people do we hire a
consultant so if we can find a
consultant there is also a type designer
that's great
if we can't we go to a graphic designer
someone that has a aesthetic sensibility
and we work very closely with that
person
like when I design tamio script I had
the fortune to find a Tamil type
designer so and I wrote really closely
together and she said oh this shape
needs to be larger or smaller and this
back and forth is very interesting
because one thing in design that is
common across any script is like this
balance of shapes you know this is like
universal and what is not universal is
what a shape mean so this is why we need
consultants and we hire consultants I
heart consultants for Cyrillic as well
so we need that we don't know so we need
consultants right thing and another
thing just a free started by the
AeroGarden VA I think maybe AI font
selection and you have fixed
characteristics of the typeface that
express your brand and then you vary
other characteristics dynamically
because you know that certain people are
more prone to click an ad if they feel
certain things but my said yes I won't
charge royalties if you go through this
one thank you hi thank you for your
presentation nowadays everybody is
talking about variable fonts it's a big
buzzword but I confess I never took 5
minutes to think about it in your
experience how do browsers deal with
kerning things like kerning and so on
kerning it's all about browsing decision
and it's on the browsing size the
browser size inside so how are dealing
with it yeah like nowadays most browsers
have a very good kerning support so for
those of you who don't know kerning is
like spacing between specific pairs of
letters okay so we just dispensing of a
specific pair of letters and nowadays
really that there's no longer the
problem like I remember that in the past
I get really frustrated when I used a
web font because the browser was not
supporting the kerning and that thing
looked messed up but nowadays that
that's not a problem
now the browser's are supporting
variable fonts not too many X's so they
are mostly supporting like weight in
optical size and not much more but it
will eventually evolve and like the type
designers need to be very really close
and see if everything is developing in
the right direction
so
the microphone I have to question one
about the variable phones when we design
when we choose some font for a text we
can remember the level of dimensions of
the phone and with the variable phones
we have a slider so is it possible also
to store to see a level a number in
order to adapt other text in the same
page for example with the same
characteristics this is the first
question
okay and the second is perhaps out of
the subject of the found this is the
following view there are the ASCII
classification and then after it was I
think the Unicode and as you are showing
new characters that are coming is there
a possibility to extend the Unicode in
order to welcome the new characters okay
they're very good questions so the first
question is if we can like create a
preset of the variable slider things
that we that we have chose like that is
not on the part of the designer that is
really on the part of the software that
handles it so from my end you can do
that like the I design when I design a
variable font that has that specific
possibility but like for instance in a
dope you you cannot have that for now
maybe they will add that in the future
with regards to the Unicode question
it's very interesting because when they
design Unicode they left white spaces so
if you look at the Unicode map there are
white spaces so that for possible new
characters to be added and I don't know
if we if you reach to a point that we
feel all the white spaces in the Unicode
map maybe we need to come up with a new
solution with the new map or extended it
in in a way so I hope I
just drew to reply a bit on the question
for example on the browser side Firefox
supports you to set a specific white
value so if you want to put for 120 you
can just do it and then you will just
reuse it all over the place if you want
to to freeze that white sighs ok thank
you
my question was so we have really this
trend of brands creating their own
phones but on the other side the store
model kind of make it look that we are
starting to work each time or on a very
specific subsets of phones because start
the popular ones the one that everybody
uses yes
so how can we try to circumvent this
tendency for monoculture of font we had
a Vatican and to strive for a more
diverse ecosystem of fonts which also
leverage all these different work from
all these designs without falling into
just half a dozen fonts that for every
website that just looked the same yes
thank you for that question
and as a designer I have that temptation
I know that if I design a specific style
I will sell a lot I really know these so
but I don't want to because constantly
doing things that are overdone and
saturate the market with things that are
already done so personally I decide that
the primary task of a type designer it's
to express themselves artistically so
this is a stance maybe not everybody can
agree but that's my stance low I want to
express myself artistically and that
will ensure diversity and I always try
to strive to go to like where can I go
where can I change this character
without losing legibility and
readability what can I do and I always
try to explore it that way but as you
said now we are living in a moment that
every like Hoover Google
like dailymotion like all these these
these brands are using like geometric
fonts so they are all look the same so
I'm against it I know that they are
doing that because branding it's not how
it was in the past because now branding
is also modular is changing it's
ever-changing like it's not like this is
our brand for the next 20 years no
longer happens so in because of that and
because they have like the financial
support to do that they just go with the
flow they go with the tendency and
tomorrow they will change their font so
that that's what I think will happen and
like for the common user try to follow
some some designers that you really like
you know find one two three fonts that
you like see you is the designer and try
to follow like on Instagram and Facebook
and see what they are doing because
especially when you're looking for
individual type designers like me and
not like really brand companies like
designers really try to do new stuff and
I think that's that's the way to go
what resources do you recommend for
comparing fonts according to legend
readability
I love google fonts but it just gives me
an example of the font and I'm a layman
I won't decide well if it's legible or
readable yeah so that's really a problem
because it is somehow a matter of
knowledge like it's the same for as
choosing a color you know or choosing a
color combination you need to have that
know-how so I don't think there is an
easy way to do that I mean I mean there
are some websites that pop you up with
some ready-made combinations I can't
remember the address at the moment but I
know that there are websites there do
that I think you should like do like a
small course like I I have a small
course on Skillshare which is how to
pick fonts and I explained like in less
than an hour how to make really good
decisions about choosing a font and I
think it's really accessible for
so I think it's knowledge at the moment
you can't have something to choose for
you especially when choosing a font
there's also a dimension of design
because you know it's your decision it's
something that expresses who you are I
think it's not only about legibility and
readability Thanks hi congratulations
for the great presentation just to very
small questions the first one is which
font did you choose for this
presentation for the title is not for
presenting the other phones that it's
self-explaining and the other one is
which tools do you usually use to create
fonts so you mentioned Adobe Illustrator
are there any other tools that are tools
of the trade for for it I don't actually
use illustrator to design phones I just
used it to test phones because that's
where the designers are so I use a
software called glyphs I'm a Mac user
it's and I use like a lot of scripts and
plugins that make my life really easier
so it's it's it's a software called
glyphs and this font is it's a font that
I design it's called point so I think I
should use a font that I design in my
own presentation Thanks
any more questions
okay so I guess we're done thank you so
much for coming
[Applause]